[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin Hart said to join us on loan from
DraftKings check out the new daily no
sweat same game parlay where new and
existing users can bet a daily NBA same
game parlay get a bonus bet back if they
lose new customers can bet five dollars
on any NBA pregame money line and win
150 in bonus bets if your team wins
Kevin Hart joining us on the program hey
you gotta be happy you got your
quarterback under contract what did you
think with uh Jalen hurts his deal
uh well deserved right
um I love it what Jalen hurts is done
in the game of football and outside of
the game of football has positioned him
to be where he is now and what I'm
highlighting is the level of
professionalism that he has put on
display right
um you're looking at a guy at his third
year and from how he handles the media
from how he uh really Embraces the role
of leader in leadership
um taking responsibility every
opportunity for good and bad right and
not looking to be the guy that's
responsible for everything he looks to
put his team first he looks to put his
plans first in any conversation and
those are the things that I watched
those are the things that I picked up so
when you're talking about investing in
someone and putting that franchise type
number
um and attaching it to a big salary all
those boxes have to check and he's done
an amazing job protecting them all and I
love that he set a new bar for other
people to follow
how did you come to the rationale that
you were going to buy an eagle an actual
eagle
well I'm going to be honest with you uh
I'm successful
when I think about the level of success
that I've been able to reach you know
you got to think outside the box right
and during this time you know I don't
think I've ever been more closer to my
franchise as a fan I felt the only way
to take the next step was to own an
eagle now I do want to say that that
eagle has attacked my entire family you
know we've had to we've had to we had to
get rid of it so I don't have it anymore
by the way I didn't get a recruitment uh
turns out when you buy an endangered
species they got a clause that says
you're on your own
so we just we just ended up sick at all
letting it fly off one of the Canyons
um out there near where I live you know
and I think it's better for that eagle
you know if I see him again it's fine
but we try to domesticate them which I
don't fear for that eagle
um did you name him Jalen hurts yeah his
name was Jalen
macaroni and cheese
I think that set him off his diet
I said he had to go when he picked me up
the eagle got me uh fly off with me you
called it quit did you cry after the
Super Bowl
my son did
my son did and that made me cry there's
actually a video that I put up man that
really hurt my heart man my youngest my
youngest is uh is five years old I'm
quite sure if anybody Google's just
Kevin Hart's son crying after he was
lost she'll see it but he was so crushed
you know because basically my my son is
taught to love the Eagles I took him to
Eagles games and he's seen us win so
it's always been a celebration of when
he never felt like the hard loss so all
week I was building it up it's the big
game are you ready son and I went to the
Super Bowl I didn't take him
and you know the the the the brothers
his brothers and sisters at the house
sent me videos of him with his jersey on
watching the game and we lost man he
just broke down he was so hurt and it it
crushed me it they crushed me but but
this is being a fan I mean that that's
the first lesson you can have the high
that's the easy part but man when the
hurt yeah when you lose and it hurts all
right now you're a fan
well I told him I said I said the beauty
of loving something is loving it through
the good and the bad and I was like it's
gonna get good again it's bad right now
except but that's why we got to be good
fans and root again you know I gave him
a good life lesson because I'm I'm full
of those
I I know you do stuff for uh DraftKings
but I'm curious the biggest bet you ever
placed on a sporting event was how much
that's just ridiculous okay I know what
you're trying to do you're trying to get
me knocked in the head that's what
you're trying to do wait wait how would
I get you knocked in there I'm just I'll
tell you the most I ever spent
I put I put three thousand dollars on a
a college bowl game so you're trying to
say you manage your money better than me
[Laughter]
what's the most you ever placed on a
game
I I am not comfortable with giving that
information but let's just say I'm not a
stranger to making a big bet
um but are you like Drake or Floyd
Mayweather type money
you know I like the fact that it's
unknown I like the fact that the world
of Kevin and his bad habits are his bad
habits right I don't believe in putting
those things out just in case things
ever hit the fan I don't like man was
because he was doing that do you have to
run it by your wife have you ever had to
run like hey I'm gonna spend money on
this hun nope because just like you
don't know she don't know so that way
the the beauty of what I do is just what
I do right nobody has something to help
that's uh I think that's golden tail to
it that makes sense
how did you get involved with DraftKings
oh man
um I can say through good relationships
right great connectivity friends of
friends that know friends made a great
introduction and that great introduction
turned into great opportunity because
there was a need
um for a certain type of content and uh
engagement and uh the world of content
that they were looking for and the want
engagement I felt them could deliver and
with the right partnership we felt that
we could do it together Kevin Hart
joining us on behalf of DraftKings does
the rock do a Power Pump before a scene
uh you know what he does do he lathers
up he puts on a bunch of baby oil you
got to take a second to get rid of that
smell yeah so there's some truths for
you it's a little inside bit for you oh
Mr baby lotion himself gotta make his
arms shiny before every scene now me I
got a natural pump and glow I like it
yeah yeah you ever see my triceps on
screen but they pop it is pop what kind
of athlete were you
are you what do you mean
a division one Prospect all across the
board
um but I don't know if you noticed
though I grew up in Thailand so a lot of
my offers came from colleges in Thailand
that's what you probably don't know
about
you were big and you were so you were
considered tall in Thailand absolutely
uh actually if you go to the website uh
thailand.edu.net.u
them was you'll see that there I was a
star I mean I did it I really did and
then I had to come to the states and
then you know I was like well do I want
to play sports anymore it was a lot
so I just stopped what was the moment
where you said I'm gonna get into comedy
was there a person or a movie a moment
I think the moment where
have really made a decision to do comedy
is when I felt like modeling
was just going to present difficulty
for the other people in the business
right like
um you know I was a model out the gate
I'm not sure if you know this but when I
was seeing early success as a model I
just started to worry if there would be
any work for others yeah or if I was
going to take it all
um and you know I was like I got another
opportunity in comedy maybe I focus on
that and I merge the world of sex appeal
and funny because nobody else was doing
it and I did it and I and I and I had a
high level of success
you never did nudes though when you were
modeling did you I did oh I did oh you
did that's why I was so big
it was huge I did it all man you know in
the beginning
you got to find your Lane right because
like what do they prefer I think they
refer to my body in the business and
sculpted I think that's what they say
it's like when it looks like somebody
drew it yeah there it is that's the word
chiseled they used to call me a small
chiseled man that's what the agents
would say I'm not sure you should know
this did you do your research no I did
not I did not do I did most of the
research had to do on other things but
but not the modeling part of this I I
didn't know that or your athleticism I
don't know how you don't have this stuff
like you your your producers should
definitely like I don't know who they
are but at this point I just wonder if
they're doing oh they're gonna be fired
yeah they'll be fired after this but but
if I said let's have a basketball game
You Drake and Floyd Mayweather
yeah
are you asking who's the best yeah
well I don't think you could have put me
in a company of two worse athletes uh
Drake AKA bad knees bad knees Bobby but
he thinks he can play he he sits
Courtside he's so close to getting in
the game Kevin one point somebody has to
ask Drake what are you doing right like
with these basketball workouts and
hiring these shooting coaches what are
you doing okay it's over
it's not going to happen it never
started for it to be over I don't think
he has the right people in his life that
are giving him hard honesty well what
about Justin Bieber Bieber can play a
little bit
Bieber can play a little bit but it's
still it's a it's a hobby it's an
extracurricular activity it's fun okay I
think Drake in his mind thinks that he's
gonna get a call I think he does he does
I think he thinks that the Toronto
Raptors are going to say are you
interested in a 10-day contract
something like he has a warped
POV as to what can happen and that's
that's my worry here that's my big worry
and Mayweather doesn't bother you
Mayweather doesn't bother me because
it's a hobby it's a hobby
you know Floyd's not trying to do it for
a living he's not out doing basketball
drills at 6 A.M
you know he's not working with NBA
coaches
well he gets it it's fun
it's great to talk to you
it's always good to talk to you man we
should do it more but I question like
The Company You Keep man next time I
would love to come in to a more well
versed uh interview just with you I had
the Eagles right I had that you got an
eagle named Jalen hurts that you let go
yeah but I just wish you knew more about
my Athletics
this would have given us more of a
highlight
that's all
is that an Audemars
on your wrist or yes it is okay okay so
somebody did a little somebody knows a
little bit about something well somebody
knows a little bit about something it's
actually great that you bring that up I
want to say Audemar yeah is an amazing
brain
um as one of the faces of the brand I
just want to say hey why don't you get
us both watches here because you know is
this about race again do you do it again
did you do it again I think I did oh my
God I think I think everything's about
race my bad
my bad uh um thanks thank you good
talking to you yeah and all all uh yes
thanks again and uh and good luck and uh
and uh talk to you soon
all right my God take it easy Kevin Hart
it's funny man
uh joining us on behalf of DraftKings
check out the new daily no sweat same
game parlay